- Hello, everyone. My name is Aditi.
I'm a Senior Product
Manager for Amazon FSx.
I'm joined by Manish Talreja,
who's the Principal Product
Manager for Amazon S3
and Mark Roper, who's the
Principal Engineer for Amazon FSx.
Mark will join Manish and
I for Q&A after the talk.
All right, so all three
of us have spent years
working directly with customers,
running high-performance workloads,
and pushing the boundaries of
what's possible with storage.
We are going to share a little
bit about what we've learned
about high-performance storage
for AI/ML analytics and HPC workloads.
We are going to walk through
some real customer use cases,
real-world examples,
dive into technical capabilities
that enable performance at scale,
and introduce exciting new
features along the way.
Let's start with a fundamental question.
Who needs high-performance storage?
And the answer is a lot
of different workloads
across a wide range of industries.
So, think about machine learning teams
running large language training
models on massive datasets,
data analysts querying
petabytes of data interactively,
or think about researchers
running weather simulations
or drug discovery with tens
and thousands of cores.
And the list goes on.
But what ties all of these
together are two things.
First, that these are
compute-intensive workloads.
So they require hundreds
and thousands of cores
CPU or GPU resources.
And second, they're all data-intensive.
They depend on fast,
reliable access to massive scale of data.
And that second part,
that's where things
really get interesting.
Let me show you how.
So we frequently hear from our customers
that they love that with AWS,
they can spin up compute clusters,
run their workload
faster than ever before,
and then spin them down
once their workload's done
and stop paying for those resources.
This is the magic of the cloud.
So ideally, you want this, you want...
As you add more compute,
more CPU, more GPU resources,
you get proportionally more work done.
Ideal linear scaling, beautiful.
Here's the problem, though.
What if you have a storage solution
that cannot keep up
with the performance
requirements of your workload,
and in that case, the work done
or your throughput plateaus.
And you can keep throwing
CPU/GPU resources,
but the performance will
not scale linearly with it.
And the reason being that
all those compute instances
are now competing for access
to the same data store,
and that data storage has
now become the bottleneck.
This is specifically painful
because we see that 90 to 95%
of spend on these workloads
is compute.
So when your compute is
sitting underutilized
waiting for data,
your time to run gets shorter
and your cost goes up.
So, in an ideal world,
when you're architecting your solution,
you would want your storage
to scale linearly with your compute
so that it never ends up
becoming a bottleneck.
And before diving right into solutions
of what we've built at AWS to
address that very bottleneck,
I want to acknowledge
that customers come to AWS
from two different parts.
On the one hand,
we have the customers that are
running HPC ML/AI workloads
on-premises for years.
Their workloads are based
on file-based access,
and they want to maintain that paradigm
and move to the cloud,
gaining the benefits of the cloud.
And on the second hand,
we have the customers who started
in the cloud from day one.
So that means that they have
their data stored in Amazon S3,
and their applications
are built around S3 APIs.
So, just for the show of hands,
who here is using file-based
applications today?
Oh, awesome.
And who here is using Amazon
S3 as their data lake?
That's pretty good, that's
a great mix of customers.
And this is also very, very
accurate representation
of what we see with our
customers in production today.
So, we are going to
cover each one of these,
but let me start with lift and
shift file system customers.
So the question remains,
why do file system remains
the preferred choice
for so many of these
high-performance workloads?
Couple reasons,
but the primary one
being familiar interface.
So, researchers, data scientists,
and developers know how to work
with files and directories.
It's just more intuitive.
The second is POSIX permissions.
So when I say POSIX permissions,
file systems give you granular access.
When you have multiple users
accessing the same data,
you want to give control,
you want to make sure
that you are controlling who
gets access to those files,
who can write and execute those files.
And the third is consistent data access.
Again, if all of your users
are accessing the same file system,
you want to make sure that
the data that they're reading
is consistent.
Consistency is guaranteed.
There are no stale reads,
and that is where file system is used.
Back in 2018,
we found that many customers
wanted all of these
benefits of file system,
along with the ease of use
and scalability of the cloud.
And that is when we
launched FSx for Lustre.
FSx for Lustre is built
on the open-source Lustre file system.
So any of you who've heard Lustre before?
Okay, that's pretty good.
So Lustre is the open-source
high-performance file system.
It is one of the most popular
high-performance file systems.
It is used by National
Labs across the world.
It is used by ML/AI and HPC applications
on-premises as well.
So, it goes from applications range
from training and inference,
all the way to weather
modeling and genomic analysis.
And so what we've done is...
Lustre's really powerful,
but it's also notoriously
complex to manage.
What we have done is basically
taken all the benefits
of the fast and scalable
Lustre file system
and combined it with the
management and ease of use
of a cloud solution.
So, we've offered a
fully-managed, fully-elastic,
and fast FSx for Lustre file system.
Let me walk you through
all of these one by one,
starting with fully managed.
So, what does fully managed means?
Fully managed means that this file system
is tested and operated at
an unprecedented scale.
We are also consistently monitoring
all the hardware resources
that are underpinning the file system.
So, assume that one of your server
runs into a hardware failure,
and in that case, we
automatically monitor it,
automatically detect it,
and replace the server
with a healthy server
to keep your file system
healthy at all times.
We've also done the heavy lifting
of ensuring that your file system
is built on the latest and
greatest technologies at AWS
and the latest and greatest
technologies offered
by the open-source Lustre community,
and make those available to
you with full API support.
All right.
Now I want to talk about elasticity.
We've made Lustre fully elastic
for the first time in the cloud.
We were hearing growing
pains from the customers
as they were scaling their
workloads in the cloud.
Growing pains, such as data
does not grow linearly.
So for instance, if you
have ML training runs,
you generate terabytes of checkpoints,
and then you clean them up.
Your simulation spikes and
then you wrap those projects.
So your data requirements
are always going up and down,
and there's this constant battle
that you never want to run out of storage,
but at the same time,
you don't want to pay for
unused capacity, right?
That's one thing.
And the second thing
is that not all your data is active data.
You're not actively using all of that data
to be stored on the SSD file system.
So, you need it for your hot data,
but you still need your
terabyte, your checkpoints,
and our results stored,
but not on the fast SSD.
Because if it is stored
on your faster SSD tier,
it gets real expensive real fast.
So, think as you're scaling
your dataset to petabyte scale.
As you go to petabyte scale,
it gets really hard to
just operationally manage
and the economies don't scale either.
That is why we launched
FSx Intelligent-Tiering
earlier this year.
So with FSx Intelligent-Tiering,
we offer virtually
unlimited storage capacity,
which means that the data grow...
that the storage capacity
grows and shrinks automatically
based on your usage.
You don't have to worry about it,
you'd never run out of storage,
and you never have to
pay for storage capacity
that you're not using.
Second point is Intelligent-Tiering
between storage tiers.
So we keep all your active
data on your fast SSD
and automatically tier
your less accessed data
to the colder, low-cost tiers.
And we manage all of this, you
don't have to worry about it.
We do it intelligently based
on your access patterns.
And finally, the economics of
it are quite compelling, too.
As an example, for the colder tier,
you pay half a cent
per gigabyte per month.
And to put this in perspective,
your overall solution
comes down to be 34% more price performant
compared to your HDD
solutions on-premises.
Now, let's talk about speed.
These are the performance levels
we are delivering in production today.
FSx for Lustre is the fastest
storage for GPUs in the cloud,
and it delivers the lowest
latencies in the cloud.
This performance metrics
are what keeps your
compute fully utilized.
Let me walk you through
how FSx for Lustre
delivers this performance,
so that you can customize your file system
based on your workload requirements.
Each of the dimensions shown here,
you can play with them independently,
and that's one of the ways
you can even make it even
further price-performant.
So, here's a simplified view.
On your left, you've got
your compute instance
that's running your workload,
and on the right, you've got your storage,
you've got your file system.
File system has two kinds of servers.
It has the metadata server
and it has the storage server.
So, your metadata server
is basically handling all
your metadata requests.
Think about creating
files, listing directories,
managing permissions,
your metadata server
takes care of all of that.
And then we have the object server.
Object server is what handles
your actual data reads and writes
to and from the file system.
Both of these servers are
backed by storage disks,
and when you talk to storage,
your compute instance
basically talks to this metadata server
and storage server over the network.
Now, I'm going to show you
how each of these
components comes into play
when we talk about performance
and how you can change those
based on your workload requirements.
Let's start with throughput.
So when you're using
multiple client instances,
you're running thousands
of training processes,
simulation jobs.
They're all accessing the same
file system simultaneously.
This means that you need more throughput,
and by throughput,
I mean how many bytes per second
you can read or write to the file system.
So, to deliver this throughput,
FSx for Lustre file system
basically scales out with
multiple storage servers
working in parallel to
serve your requests.
This parallel distribution
across hundreds of storage servers
is how we deliver over
one terabytes per second
of aggregate throughput.
So, when all of your compute instances
are talking to the file system,
your requests are going to not one,
but multiple servers, in parallel,
and you're getting the power
of those multiple servers every time.
And that's how you get
over terabyte per second
of aggregate throughput.
This enables fast parallel data access
to hundreds and thousands of cores.
All right, now most
high-performance workloads
are heavy on throughput and
relatively light on metadata.
But recently, we started noticing
that customers were using FSx for Lustre
for more metadata-intensive workloads.
So you can think about home directories,
user research workstations,
and interactive applications
where you're con constantly
listing to directories,
opening files, checking permissions.
So last year, we launched a capability
to scale out your metadata servers,
very similar to your storage servers.
Again, your metadata servers
can be scaled out independent
of your storage servers
and your storage capacity.
What this helps with is you
get 15X higher metadata IOPS
when compared to before when
you could not scale out.
And we are further doubling down
and making sure that you don't run
into metadata bottlenecks.
Recently, we made an update
to the Lustre software,
which enables 5X higher
directory listing performance.
Now, I walked you through
aggregate throughput,
I walked you through metadata IOPS
of the file system as a whole.
Now, I want to talk about
what happens when you have...
What happens with a
single compute instance
interacting with the file system.
Why am I even talking about
a single compute instance?
So we have a file...
We have seen that EC2 instances on Amazon,
and across the board compute instances
have really improved
when it comes to their network bandwidth.
We've gone from 25 gigabits, 200,
to now 3,200 gigabit per
second with P5 instances.
And all of this performance is great,
but it's not amazing when
you cannot leverage it
when talking to storage.
So when you're looking at
a traditional file system,
your traditional file system
generally talks to your compute
instances or TCP network,
and it only interacts with one
NIC on the compute instance,
which was true for FSx for Lustre as well
for two years back.
You're only interacting with
one NIC, and because of that,
your throughput gets limited
to 100 gigabits per second,
and that means you're
leaving so much throughput
on the table.
So what we did was we launched EFA,
EFA support.
EFA is Elastic Fabric Adapter,
which is built on Amazon's SRD protocol.
What it helps you do
is it helps you communicate
with the compute instance
across multiple NICs,
and it bypasses the operating
system layer completely.
And how that is helpful
is now you're not using
a lot of your CPU cores
in figuring out which
NIC to communicate with.
And it's much more faster,
it can scale up to 700
gigabits per second.
And obviously knowing the power of GPUs,
we wanted to ensure
that we are utilizing it
to the most optimal levels.
We also support NVIDIA GPUDirect Storage.
How many of you have heard
about NVIDIA GPUDirect Storage?
All right.
We've got a lot of storage
folks here, I love that.
So for NVIDIA GPUDirect Storage,
what happens is your computer instances
can basically bypass the CPU
and talk directly to your GPU memory.
Think about a general data
path going from your storage,
to your CPU memory, to your GPU memory.
That's multiple hubs
that need to be managed.
But what happens with GPUDirect
is it allows the file system
to communicate directly
with your GPU memory,
allowing us to give you a throughput
of 3,200 gigabits per second per client.
So 12X higher.
All right, finally, let's
talk about latencies.
When we built FSx for Lustre,
we architected it to offer
the lowest possible latencies
on AWS.
When I say latencies,
we are talking about how long it takes
for a small operation to perform.
So it affects the overall responsiveness
of your storage solution.
A lot of workloads we work with,
large compute clusters processing data
while at the same time,
end users or researchers
are also manipulating
that data interactively.
And for these human in the loop use cases,
having fast responsive
storage really matters
because it should not
feel like you're setting
for seconds or minutes just
to wait for your file to open
or do an operation that really
matters for a researcher.
Now, how do we get
sub-millisecond latencies
beyond just having an SSD disk
for your active training data?
Three things.
First of all, we allow you to...
FSx for Lustre is a
zonal storage offering.
So you can keep your file system
in the same AZ as your
storage, as your compute.
So that means just at a very low level,
the distance that the data has to travel
is really minimized,
and that helps in improving latencies.
Second is we do
point-to-point communication,
which is single-network roundtrip.
Your client server
can directly talk to
your file system server
without multiple network hubs.
What you would've seen
with most storage solutions
is there are multiple network
hops through the server
or there are load balancers.
And while they're there
for like very good reasons,
they do have an impact
on the latency of the storage offering.
And the third one is client
side read and write caching.
So with FSx for Lustre,
I like to say that we consider client
as part of the file system.
So anytime you read and write,
if you're reading and
writing say similar files
over and over again,
FSx for Lustre can cache
those on your client.
So in that case,
you're basically having
no network hops at all
and even lower latencies.
So FSx for Lustre allows you
to get about zero to one network ops
and sub-millisecond latencies.
I've thrown a lot of
theoretical information at you,
and now I want to share how this happens.
How this works in production.
Shell is a great example.
Shell had a GPU-based on-prem environment
where they were running into
infrastructure bottlenecks.
So, this decided to burst into cloud
with FSx for Lustre and EC2.
They wanted to leverage the ability
to scale compute and storage up and down
based on their user requirements.
Now, how this helped
was they were able to
increase their GPU utilization
from less than 90% to 100% in the cloud.
So, with FSx for Lustre,
Shell was able to fully
utilize the compute resources
at full throttle.
And these 10, 11-point
percentage difference
might not seem a lot,
but those of you who
are using P5 instances,
this really accumulates really fast.
And that concludes the file section part
of the presentation.
Now, I want to hand over to Manish
to share the options and optimizations
for S3 data lake customers.
- All right.
Thanks, Aditi. Where are
my data lake customers?
Great. How many of you have
heard of Express One Zone?
Awesome, a few.
So, we'll talk about:
How do you reduce storage bottlenecks
with cloud object storage?
Many of you already have
petabytes of data stored
on S3 data lakes.
Now, this is because
you love the durability,
the scalability, and
the cost-effectiveness.
Now, this is why S3 provides you
with purpose-built storage classes, right?
You're starting from S3 Standard,
that's for your frequently-accessed data;
Glacier, for your longtime archival;
and Intelligent-Tiering,
when you have changing
data access patterns.
Now, this makes it very easy
for you to source your
data directly from S3,
but here's the critical point.
Your storage must keep
up with your compute.
And as other team mentioned earlier,
compute is your most expensive resource.
And when the storage cannot keep up,
you will waste money on idle CPU or GPUs.
With that said,
I want you to focus your attention
on one particular storage
class on the left.
This is Amazon S3 Express One Zone.
This is our fastest cloud object storage,
and it's built specifically
for performance-critical applications.
It will give you 10 times faster access
and 80% lower request
costs than S3 Standard.
Now, let's look at what
makes it different.
First, Express One Zone
is a single Availability
Zone of storage class,
and we built it specifically
to deliver single-digit millisecond...
Consistent single-digit millisecond access
for your most frequently accessed data.
Now, it instantly scales to
hundreds of thousands of TPS
with a new bucket type
called directory buckets.
Now, for the rest of the talk,
we will focus on S3 Express One Zone,
but some of the techniques
that we talk about
will apply to S3 Standard as well.
All right, so before we dive
into optimization techniques,
let's think about a mental
model that we will use.
So, when your client
sends a request to S3,
there are two parts to the request.
The part on the left that's in white
is called overhead or time to first bite.
This is where your client
sets up the connection,
sets up the authentication,
there's the roundtrip time.
S3 is locating where your data
is and then serving it up.
Now, no data is being
transferred during this time.
And then there's the second part in pink.
This is where the actual
data transfer happens.
We're gonna use this mental model
for how we can evaluate your workloads.
Now, there are two workloads
on the screen right now,
the top and bottom, they
have the same overhead.
This is the part in white.
But notice the difference
in the data payload.
On the top, you will see a
much smaller data payload.
When your transfers look like this,
your workload is latency sensitive.
So think of KV caching, your
shuffle charting workloads,
your realtime inference serving,
and this is where your
overhead matters a lot more.
And on the bottom,
you'll see a larger data payload
compared to the overhead.
Now, when your transfers look like this,
you care about the total
transfer time or your throughput.
So now that we have a mental model,
let's talk about how we can optimize
for different parameters,
different performance parameters.
Let's start with latency.
Now, we're gonna talk about
two different techniques
that you can use with S3 Express One Zone.
The first one is co-locating
your compute instances
with S3 One Zone directory buckets.
When you do that, your data
travels shorter distances,
you have a few much fewer network hops.
And what that lets you do
is reduce the latency that
you have to the storage.
Now, co-locating might
not always be possible.
Now, in these situations,
you can still take advantage
of the latency optimizations,
but you might pay a
little bit of a penalty
when you go across AZ.
So if your computer's in an adjacent AZ
from your directory bucket.
The second technique is
session-based authentication.
Now, this is a new
technique that we introduce
with directory buckets.
Now, traditionally, with
S3 Standard buckets,
what you would use is IAM authentication.
With S3 directory buckets,
you would use something called
a session-based authentication.
You would create...
You would call it an API
called create session.
This will give you a token.
Your application will cache
this for a period of time
and reuse that
so that you don't incur a latency hit
when you are authorizing
with a directory bucket.
Now, we understand that
not every application
can change overnight.
So you can still start
with IAM authentication
and then move over to session auth
when you want to optimize for latency.
And whenever you're
diagnosing high latency,
we always ask customers
to look under the hood
into their libraries
and make sure that
session auth is enabled.
Okay, so latency often goes hand in hand
with transactions per second.
A lot of the workloads that
you run with small latency
are request-intensive, have
request-intensive operations.
So think of large-scale
analytics or shuffle charting.
And with S3 general purpose buckets,
if you're familiar with how do
you optimize for higher TPS,
you would do that through
prefix management.
And the way S3 works is
it scales with prefix.
So it adds TPS capacity
when you have constant load.
Constant load and it'll basically scale up
after a period of time, but it takes time.
With Express One Zone,
you don't need to do any of that.
We handle the partitioning under the hood.
And for each directory bucket,
we'll give you 200K reads
per second out of the box.
And of course we are continually
innovating on your behalf.
So this year, we added optimizations
to go up to 2 million
transactions per second.
Now, a couple of quick tips.
When you are working
with directory buckets,
you should try to keep
your directories dense.
What does that mean, right?
So you should try to flatten
your directory structure
and keep the objects in the leaf nodes
and put a lot more
object in the leaf nodes.
And the second tip is don't add entropy.
Typically, we advise you to
add entropy in your prefixes
for your S3 Standard buckets.
Here, this will actually slow you down.
All right, let me share with you
how this really works in practice.
Tavily is an AI infrastructure company,
and they're building a web
access layer for agents
and large language models.
They manage a two-tier caching system
and their costs were rising.
They would've had to
double their investment
to change their hot...
Double their investment
for their hot cache layer.
Instead, they chose S3 Express One Zone
because it delivered the low latency
and the cost efficiency
they were looking for.
This is for their hot cache layer.
In addition, it just scaled automatically
as their data grew.
You can see the results.
They were able to cut costs by six times
while improving
performance and reliability
across millions of user requests.
So this is latency and
transactions per second in play.
Now, let's talk about high throughput.
Now many of you are running workloads,
like large-scale ML training
or research workloads.
This is where data loading
and checkpointing becomes important.
You need massive throughput
so that you keep your
compute fully utilized.
So one of the techniques
we're gonna talk about
is parallelization.
Now, since S3 scales horizontally,
the way to increase throughput
is by breaking up your requests
across multiple connections.
In this example over here,
you can see that each connection
can achieve 100 megabytes per second.
Now, if you need gigabytes per second
or terabytes per second, you
open up multiple connections.
So, how do you accomplish
this with APIs, right?
So when you're downloading,
use bite range gets.
This is where you will
download parts of the object,
and then you'll have to assemble
that on your compute node.
If you want to upload,
you use a similar technique
called multi-part uploads,
where you would upload individual parts,
and S3 will assemble that for you.
All right, so I'm very
excited about this example.
This was mentioned by Andy in
the keynote yesterday as well.
Meta FAIR is a research organization
that runs research workloads,
including LLM training
across thousands of GPUs.
They wanted to speed
up their checkpointing
and data loading,
and what they did was they
used S3 Express One Zone.
We scaled up an AZ with 60
petabytes of data in one AZ,
where their GPU clusters were located.
And they were able to sustain
140 terabytes per second
with over 1 million
transactions per second.
Isn't that neat?
Okay, so let's talk about the
client-side optimizations.
We saw that some customers
were not able to fully
utilize the compute resources
using the techniques
that we just discussed.
So, we built the AWS
Common Runtime, or CRT.
Anybody heard of CRT over here?
Oh, not many people, this is great.
So, let's talk about it, right?
So, it's a set of open-source libraries,
and what we did was we
embedded these libraries
right into all our SDKs,
all our clients, all our connectors.
So you get performance improvements
with S3 right out of the box.
The great thing is you
don't have to change much.
An example here is that CRT
will deliver up to six times
faster data transfer with CLI
using some of the techniques
that we just discussed, right?
Just keep in mind that for PMTRN,
the larger instances, we
enable the CRT by default.
However, if you're using
some other instances,
please look under the hood,
you might have to enable
this and opt in into CRT,
so that you can take advantage
of some of these techniques.
So, similar to how Aditi
spoke about multiple NICs
and how you can increase
the per instance throughput.
We have a similar feature in AWS CRT.
So instances such as P5 and P6
can achieve 800 gigabits per
second theoretical bandwidth
over their EN8 network interfaces, right?
So this CRT feature
allows you to distribute your connections,
your S3 connections, over all
of these network interfaces.
Now, this is particularly
important if you're using EFA
for your compute-intensive workloads.
It prevents EFA slowdowns,
and your compute and storage traffic
can both run optimally
if you spread the load.
How do you do that?
It's as simple as just setting the config
and picking the network interfaces
that you need using CRT.
Let's look at some sample results.
So, we ran tests on a
DL 24 Excel instance.
We downloaded 10 30-gigabyte files.
When we added a second NIC,
we were able to almost
double the performance.
We could get almost double the throughput.
With four NICs,
we were able to get about
2.5 times the performance
compared to a single NIC.
Now, the scaling doesn't look linear,
but you will get some
meaningful throughput gains
when you add multiple NICs.
But the more important thing
is that you can spread your traffic
or even pin a particular
NIC to your process,
so this will help you
optimize how you control.
This will help you optimize your workloads
when you're using a much larger instance.
Okay, let's talk a little bit
about integrations, right?
So, these were all libraries
that we spoke about,
but we heard from customers
that they didn't want to
change their application
and they wanted to take
these best practices
and use them with the existing
frameworks that they had.
This is why we develop
purpose-built integrations
so that you could take performance off S3.
We're gonna only talk about three of them,
but we have a lot more integrations
that we have developed.
So the first one is the PyTorch connector,
and when you use PyTorch,
you have to build your own data primitives
to load and save data when
you wanna load the data
or you wanna run checkpoints.
So, we wanted to give you a
high-performance integration
that took care of a lot of this.
This is where the S3 connector
for PyTorch comes in.
Now, this gives you dataset,
this gives you built-in
PyTorch dataset primitives
and it supports both map-style datasets.
This is for your random access data
and iterable-style datasets,
which is when you're
streaming sequential data.
Now, for checkpointing,
the connector automatically integrates
with the PyTorch distributed
checkpointing support.
With this, you can checkpoint
directly into S3 Express One Zone
and you can bypass the local NVMe.
What we found was that you could get
up to 40% performance increase
by bypassing the local storage
and going directly to S3 Express One Zone.
New for 2025,
we've accelerated partial
checkpoint loading by 60%.
So this is another example
of how we're innovating on your behalf.
How many people here work
with Parquet datasets?
Awesome, quite a few.
So, you probably already
know that your query engine
has to read metadata from Parquet files,
and this metadata is stored
at the footer of these Parquet files.
This metadata stores information
about the file structure
and what the schema is.
So, when you're scanning
across multiple of these files,
what you will see is that the metadata
will slow down your query execution.
So this is where the S3
Analytics Accelerator comes in.
This is an open-source library.
It pre-fetches metadata
using bite range gets,
it reads the footer,
and it also caches this
footer for subsequent reads.
So this eliminates
quite a bit of overhead.
We tested this with TPC-DS.
This is a benchmark that you can run.
And we saw that we were able to achieve
up to 27% performance improvement
just by using the Analytics Accelerator.
Another integration I wanna
talk about is SageMaker.
Now, if you're not familiar
with Amazon SageMaker,
it's our fully managed service,
and it's built for building, training,
and deploying machine learning models.
Now, when you're running training jobs,
you need to load your training
data often millions of,
if not lots of small files,
like images or text samples.
And this will generate
millions of requests per second
into storage.
Now, this is where our S3
Express One Zone integration
with SageMaker Fast File mode comes in.
Now, what Fast File mode will do
is it will stream data
directly from Express One Zone
into your training instance,
bypass the local disk,
and accelerate your training performance.
Now, since Express One Zone
scales to hundreds of thousands of TPS,
you should be able to see
meaningful performance increases
with this approach.
Great, so earlier,
Aditi covered how you
can optimize interfaces
for high-performance...
File interfaces for
high-performance workloads.
We went through some
optimizations for object storage,
but what if you already have a lot of data
in your object store
and you want to use a file
interface to access that?
So this is where will show you
how you can bridge the two.
- Thanks, Manish.
All right, I'm only going to
speak for five more minutes
and this is the favorite
part of my presentation.
So, listen up.
So, I shared a lot about
high-performance file systems,
Lustre file systems, fully managed,
fully elastic in the
beginning of my presentation.
And if any of that resonated
with you, where you felt,
"Oh, well, my data is already
stored in S3 data lake,"
then don't worry, we got you.
We basically have the option
to connect your file system
with your S3 bucket.
This is also just a general
paradigm we use within AWS
that we want to meet where you are at,
and we want to minimize the
work that you have to do
to move to the cloud or run
your applications in the cloud.
Let me show you how this works.
So with FSx for Lustre,
you can create a file system
and link it to the S3 bucket.
Under the covers, this is your S3 bucket.
It has all the objects,
all the data stored in it.
When you connect your file
system to the S3 bucket
and try to read and write data
from your compute instance,
what it does is it immediately
takes all your metadata
from your S3 bucket
and shows it as file
metadata on the file system.
So for you, it would seem like the data
is actually on the file system.
When you try to read and write
data onto the file system,
FSx for Lustre will automatically go
and fetch that data from S3.
Now, and another interesting fact here
is that we take care of
bi-directional synchronization.
So, any changes you're
making to the file system,
we are exporting those
changes to the S3 bucket.
And any changes you make to the S3 bucket,
we import those changes to the file system
completely hands-off for you
and fully managed in the back end.
You can think of this
as a file system cache
in front of your S3 bucket.
Let's look at a performance
when a file system
is in front of S3.
We took a Kaggle liver dataset
stored as a public S3 dataset
and measured the time to
do patient classification
with different setups.
So the first one that you see right there
is where you have your data stored in S3,
you load it to your local storage
and then you train against
that local storage.
What we did was we tried to do a test,
where we used FSx for Lustre as a cache
between your compute
instance and your S3 bucket.
In the first run of that model,
we saw a 67% increase in performance.
Now, that increase in performance work
was coming from two things.
The first one, you see that
green color over there?
That is the data loading time,
where your compute instance
is copying the data
and it has to copy the data,
wait for it to be completely loaded
before it can start training.
With FSx for Lustre,
you spin up your instance
and you start training immediately.
So we save on the data loading time.
And second is just pure performance
that a Fast File system delivers,
which leads to this
cumulative impact of 67%.
Now, this was the first run,
where FSx for Lustre was still going to S3
to get that data for you.
In the second run onwards,
you would see that the
performance is improved by 83%,
and that's because the
data is already cached
onto the file system.
So finally, one last customer example
to bring all of this together for you.
LG AI Research.
This AI research lab within LG
wanted to create a foundational model
that mimics human brain.
So they decided to build their own model
using Amazon SageMaker and FSx for Lustre.
On the left, you see
that they store machine
learning training data
in their S3 bucket.
And for performance and a file interface,
they created a Lustre file
system linked to that S3 bucket
and their SageMaker training
jobs was directly talking...
was directly accessing their
data through the file system.
When workloads finish,
model artifacts get written back to S3
for long-term storage and for inference.
So they use S3 for longer term storage,
FSx for Lustre for their
highest-performing hot data
to accelerate their training run times
and getting the best performance
out of their instances.
This concludes the presentation we had.
We basically try to cover
high-performance storage options
depending upon whether you're
looking to lift and shift
from on-premises,
or you prefer prefer a
file system interface,
which is FSx for Lustre,
or if you have an S3 native application
where you can use S3 Express One Zone.
And then if you already...
Or if you prefer file system interface
but your data is stored in S3,
then you can basically
mount your file system
to the S3 bucket.
Thank you, all, for attending.
If you haven't already,
please complete the survey.
You should get a notification in your app.
Manish, Mark, and I will stick around
to answer any questions you have
on anything related to
high-performance storage.
- [Manish] All right.
- [Aditi] Thank you.
(audience applauding)